Die Berliner sind wieder draußen,
probieren, wie es sich lebt
nach dem Lockdown im Land.
Und ja: Manches fühlt sich fast an
wie früher –
bevor die Welt stillstand wegen Corona.
Wochenlang blieben Geschäfte,
Gastronomie und Spielplätze geschlossen.
Jetzt kehrt ein bisschen Alltag
in die Hauptstadt zurück,
und die meisten sind darüber erleichtert.
Allerdings müssen die Berliner
jetzt selbst dafür sorgen,
dass der Schutz ihrer Mitmenschen
gewahrt bleibt.
Ob das funktioniert?
Hin und her geht die Meinung der Deutschen:
zu viel Vorsicht oder zu wenig, die
Lockerungen zu früh oder zu spät.
Es ist eine Probe für den Zusammenhalt
der Gesellschaft.
Ich schätze die Solidarität der Gesellschaft
schon sehr hoch ein
und denke, dass auch viele Menschen sich
bewusst sind,
dass sie auch die Träger sein können und da
auch solidarisch miteinander umgehen.
Dass alle tatsächlich mitspielen
beim Schutz gegen das Virus,
dieses Gefühl teilt hier
in Berlin-Neukölln nicht jeder.
Vor allem Ältere machen sich Sorgen.
Brauchst ja bloß hier mal rumgehen
am Wochenende,
dann siehst du, dass Party ist überall –
richtig mit 20, 30 Beteiligten.
Wenn du jung bist, denkst du dir,
du kannst es krachen lassen.
Ausreichend Abstand wahren:
In diesem Park im Prenzlauer Berg
halten sich die meisten daran.
Was kann man tun, was sollte man lassen?
Das selbst zu entscheiden,
fällt offenbar schwer.
Insgesamt ist es eher so eine
Pseudo-Solidarität,
dass du dich quasi schnell anpassen kannst,
wenn du jetzt beobachtet wirst.
In Berlin-Kreuzberg geht es zwangloser zu.
Für manche ist die Pandemie
anscheinend wieder vorbei.
Andere zweifeln, ob es sie überhaupt gibt.
Öffentlich zugeben will das aber niemand.
Der Markt der Meinungen ist unübersichtlich.
Es ist halt ein wissenschaftliches Thema.
Und es ist natürlich schwierig für Menschen,
die erst mal nur sich gar nicht so täglich
mit diesen Fakten,
oder wie auch immer, auseinandersetzen,
einen Schritt aufeinander zuzumachen,
weil die einen geben sich als die
Superexperten aus und die anderen handeln
eher aus ihrer eigenen
emotionalen Wahrnehmung.
Wie umgehen mit der Corona-Pandemie?
Auch die Berliner ringen mit dieser Frage.
Und dieser ältere Herr besinnt sich
auf ganz eigene Weise.
Are also on the faces of people going by.
I see friends shaking hands, saying: „How do
you do?”
They’re really saying: „I love you” …